jouera vous hébergez merci d'être avec
nous en direct ce matin sur arte france
vendre ces tests hors pharmacie
votre avis là-dessus est ce que c'est
une bonne mesure
une bonne une mauvaise mesure c'est pas
forcément la question
sur la vente le problème c'est la vente
en gms et comment c'est fait si vous
voulez c'est à dire que encore une fois
on a une pression de la gms qui qui a
commandé des tests qui étaient interdits
à la vente et qui du jour au lendemain
ce sont autorisés à la vente dans l'eure
dans leur circuit de distribution il est
là le problème c'est à dire que l'on
prend au mot neil à la santé des
français sous couvert de dire que ça va
être moins cher on oublie que d'un test
senti génique c'est pas un paquet de
pâtes
quand on fait un test anti geniki un
accompagnement je parle de l'autotest
évidemment c'est pas malheureusement
l'hôtesse de caisse qui va dire qui va
expliquer aux clients comment utiliser
ce produit et que faire derrière il est
là le souci c'est qu'on mélange tout il
sait pas du tout du tout dans l'intérêt
du consommateur parce que l'on parle
vraiment de consommateurs donc en grande
surface nous en officine on parle de
deux patients on a des personnes qu'on
vaccine à qui on explique pourquoi on
vaccine on explique pourquoi le pass
sanitaires on explique les gestes
barrière mais ça tout ça c'est occultée
au profit justement de d'un point de vue
monétique qui fait par la grande
distribution elle est là la
problématique c'est qu'on mélange tout
et on modélise encore une fois la santé
des français alors on parle aussi de
risque de pénurie des autotests
et certains évoquent une pénurie
organisée
qu'en pensez vous
alors vous vous posez effectivement
l'arrêt bonne question c'est comment un
réseau de 22 mille officines répartis
dans tout le territoire avec des
circuits d'approvisionnement qui sont
dans le monde entier des livraisons deux
fois par jour c'est à dire que vous
voulez un produit en 12 heures vous
l'avez
en officine s'il n'est pas présent via
des grossistes répartiteurs donc avec
des tensions d'approvisionnement et la
du jour au lendemain la grande
distribution arrive à nous dire que elle
en a plein elle en a plein ses hangars
et que c'est est normal en sons sont
interdits à la vente chez eux on nous
refait le coup des masques vous souvenez
les masques il y en avait plus mais dans
nos dans nos grandes surfaces dans leur
entrepôt ils en avaient plein avant mais
si vous voulez s'ils sont tellement
s'ils veulent le bien être des français
qui les offrent gratuitement ces tests
mais là on est vraiment sur quelque
chose de encore une fois c'est
lamentable de d'utiliser ses
ficelles pour faire croire que la grande
surface va apporter des solutions
français je rappelle que c'est les mêmes
qui à quelques années nous vendait des
lasagnes au boeuf est dedans il y avait
du il y avait du cheval de dante donc il
ya des moments faut se poser les bonnes
questions juste cette question est-ce
qu'il va y avoir un impact sur le pré
des autotests ou pas ou
alors de façon le prix des tests et this
is in ovo nos politiques a été honnête
il aurait été jusqu'au bout c'est à dire
que le prix comme pour les masquer le
prix des des autotests est encadré
maintenant je vais vous dire une chose
c'est que nous on les a provisionné dans
l'urgence on est on les a fait venir par
avion pour qu'il soit disponible pour
les pour les françaises et les français
au moment des fêtes donc on les a payé
assez cher est aujourd'hui la grande
distribution se dit être capable de les
vendre moins cher que ce que nous on les
a payées donc il ya un problème quand
même si l'état veut nous aider qu'elles
nous aident à les acheter et quelle
qu'elles anticipent les
leur position puisque on est informé la
veille pour le lendemain comme pour la
vaccination on nous dit vous allez
pouvoir vacciner le dimanche mais nos
équipes sont déjà fatigués bon on a on a
on obtient les informations en même
temps que le grand public il ya aucun
travail préparatoire avec des
contradictions et des choses qui
changent tous les jours c'est très con
on sait que bon vous l'avez un peu
évoquée mais on sait qu'il ya des
questions qui se posent autour de la
fiabilité des autotests
le fait d'acheter un autotest en grande
surface aujourd'hui l'utiliser
quelles conséquences cela peut avoir sur
le long terme puisqu'on sait que c'est
une décision si prises par le
gouvernement pour faire face à l'arrivée
massive d'eau mikron sur le territoire
et l'explosion des cas que l'on connaît
actuellement
effectivement le problème il est là
c'est que c'est une information qui doit
être correcte il ya de la pédagogie qui
doit se mettre en place moi même en
officine j'ai une personne qui était
testée positive avec un test antigénique
elle avait fait chez nous elle va faire
un peu d'air dans un laboratoire a été
testée positive elle retourne chez elle
elle fait son auto test il se révèle
négatif il ya des moments où il faut se
poser aussi la question de savoir
comment on accompagne faut expliquer que
l'autotest c'est un geste supplémentaire
pour éviter la contamination mais c'est
pas tout c'est moins fiable qu'un qu'un
test antigénique les autotests doivent
être fluides utilisés quand il ya un
doute quand on vole une réunion de
famille ou même une autre un autre type
de réunions qui sont là pour sécuriser
mais en aucun cas remplacer des tests
antigénique ou des tests pcr et encore
une fois c'est l'accompagnement qui est
important parce que une personne qui va
être testé positif qu'est ce qu'elle va
faire si elle le dit à personne elle
peut continuer à être a contaminé alors
que nous quand on est en officine qui
compte est quelqu'un de positif on
appelle la caisse d'assurance maladie
ont déclaré il ya un traître à singh un
vrai accompagnement qui se met en place
si la personne se retrouve positive où
elle peut dire bon bah je suis positive
mais elle peut contaminer personnes le
personne n'était informé et donc il ya
des inquiétudes que vous soulignez au
niveau de l'accompagnement pédagogique
autour de ces au total ça c'est grêle
inquiétudes
oui c'est tout à fait c'est vous savez
vous retrouvez avec un autotest non le
voile officines les questions qu'on a
c'est pas simple de se mettre quelque
chose dans le nez est-ce qu'on va assez
bien est-ce qu'on fait bien la
manipulation comment on interprète
l'autotest c'est pas juste vendre
quelque chose et encore une fois c'est
pas une hôtesse de caisse d'un
supermarché qui a eu beaucoup de
portiques la vente qui va expliquer à la
personne comment faire on mélange tout
c'est ça le problème un accompagnement
expliquer les gestes marié bien beaucoup
de gestes sont bly on est là pour les
répéter et c'est comme ça qu'on va
réussir à endiguer cette pandémie
c'est en faisant respecter les gestes
barrière en répétant les choses à faire
ou à ne pas faire il l'a on se met le
doigt dans l'oeil avec des autotests
qu'on vend partout et qu'on peut faire
n'importe comment il est là le problème
c'est faire les choses n'importe comment
et on est reparti encore sur un travers
qui va qui va certainement au départ est
peut-être une bonne idée mais se révéler
être une mauvaise idée parce qu'à la fin
on va avoir un nom d'aucun domination
qui risque d'augmenter et en plus de ne
pas le savoir on ne saura pas
merci beaucoup à vous y aurait deux
bergers je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat des
pharmaciens de paris